Thank you. So this is the, uh,
this a talk. This is the book
shot a Taz one,
a my first ever clickbait title.
And I liked the cover I've covered
because for two reasons, one,
there's only one button that says okay,
when it's clearly not okay
and it looks like this
thing's been throwing error
messages of the past hour and
nobody has been paying
any attention to them.
So this is a book is a computer and
what I'm writing about is security in a
world where everything is a computer
and I think this is the way we need to
conceptualize the world.
We're building this smart,
this phone is not a phone,
it's a computer that makes phone calls.
And similarly your microwave oven is a
computer that makes things hot and your
refrigerators or computer
than make keeps things cold.
And the ATM machines computer with money
inside and in a car is now a computer
with four wheels and an engine,
actually that's wrong.
A car is about a hundred plus distributed
system with four wheels and an engine.
All right, so, and this is more than
the Internet. It's again at a things,
but it's more than that as well. In
my book, I use the term Internet plus.
I hate having to invent a term,
but there really isn't a term
we have for the Internet,
the computers,
the things,
the big systems like power plants,
the data stores, the processes,
the people,
and it's that holistic system
that I think we need to look at.
Let me look at security.
So if everything is becoming a computer,
it means two things that are relevant
here that all internet security becomes
everything security and all the lessons
and problems of Internet and computers
become problems everywhere.
So let me start with six sort of
quick lessons of computer security,
which will be true about
everything and everywhere.
Some them are obvious and
computers not so obvious elsewhere.
I the first most software is
poorly written and insecure, right?
We know this basic reason is the market
doesn't want to pay for quality software
like good, fast, cheap, pick any two.
We have picked fast and cheap over good,
right?
With with very expensive exceptions
like avionics and the space shuttle.
Most software is really lousy.
It kind of just barely works
now for security, right?
Lots of vulnerabilities, some of those
vulnerable. So I started lots of bugs,
some of those bugs of vulnerabilities.
Some of those vulnerabilities
are exploitable,
which modern software has lots of
exploitable vulnerabilities and that's not
going to change anytime soon.
The second lesson is that the Internet
was never designed with security in mind.
That seems ridiculous today,
but have you think back to
the late seventies and early
eighties there were two
things that were true. One, the Internet
was used for nothing important ever
and two you had to be a member of a
research institution had access to it
and you read the early designers and
they talked about how fear limiting
physical access was a security measure
and in fact you would exclude bad actors
meant that you didn't have
to worry much about security.
So decision was made deliberately
to leave security end point,
not put in the network
but fast forward today and we are still
living with the results of that in Dum,
Dum domain name system and routing and
packet security email addresses sort of
again and again. The protocols don't
have security and we are stuck with them.
Third lesson,
the extensibility of computerized systems
means they can be used against us.
Extensibility is not something that
non computer people are used to.
Basically what I mean by that is you
can't constrain the functionality of a
computer because it's software.
When I was a kid I had a telephone,
big black thing attached to the wall,
great device,
but no matter how hard I tried,
I couldn't make it be anything
other than a telephone.
This is a computer that makes phone
calls. It can do anything you want, right?
There's an app for that because this can
be programmed because it's a computer.
It can do anything. You can't
constrain this functionality, right?
It means several things for security,
hard to test this thing because what
it does changes how it's configured,
changes and it can get additional
features you don't want.
That's what malware is,
so you can put malware on this phone or
on inner catheter to fridgerator in a
way that you can't possibly ever do
it in an old electrical mechanical
refrigerator because
they're not computers.
Fourth lesson is about complexity.
A lot of ways I can say this,
basically the complexity of computers
means attack is easier than defense.
I could spend an hour on that sentence,
but complex systems are hard to secure in.
It's the most complex machine
mankind has ever built by a lot,
which makes this incredibly
hard to secure, hard to design,
securely hard to test,
so everything about it,
it is easier to attack a
system than to defend it.
Our fifth lesson is that
there are new vulnerabilities,
the interconnections as we
connect things to each other,
vulnerabilities and one thing affect
other things. I had lots of examples.
The Dine Bot net at vulnerabilities
in a connected route was digital video
recorders and Webcam is primarily allowed
an on to create a Bot net that dropped
the domain name server.
That intern dropped a couple
of dozen real popular websites.
I 2013 target corporation attack through
a vulnerability in the Hvac contractor
of several of their
mid Pennsylvania stores
earlier this year is a story
of a casino in Las Vegas.
We don't have the name of the casino.
They had their high roller database
stolen and the hackers got in through,
and I'm not making this up,
they're internet connected fish tank.
So right vulnerabilities,
this can be hard cause
sometimes nobody's at fault.
I reblogged a few months ago about a
vulnerability that results from the way
Google treats email addresses,
right?
The dots don't matter for your name and
the way Netflix streets email addresses,
the dots do matter. Turns out you
can play some games with that.
Who Do we blame?
I'm not sure we blame anybody.
There's a vulnerability in PGP, which
is actually not really vulnerability.
Impeached, speeds, vulnerability,
and the way emailers handle PGP,
which everyone's convinced
everyone else was at fault
and these kinds of things is
going to happen more and more.
The last lesson is that
attacks always get better.
Tax always get easier,
faster, cheaper, right?
Some of this is Moore's law.
Computers get faster,
so password guessing gets faster
as computer, it gets faster,
not because we're smarter about it,
but we also get smarter.
Attackers adapt, attackers figure out
new things and expertise flows downhill.
What today is a top secret NSA program?
Tomorrow becomes a Phd thesis and
the next day as a common hacker tool,
and you can see this again and again,
and an example might be a Imsi catchers,
fake cell phone towers, sting rays,
right?
Which when I mean the cause of them is a,
that cell phones don't authenticate to
tower. They automatically trust any,
anybody says, I'm a tower. So
if you put up a fake tower,
you can now query phones and get their,
uh,
addresses that sort of know who's
there. Now, this was something that, uh,
the NSA, the FBI used big
government secret for awhile.
Uh,
expertise flowed downhill a few years ago,
I think it was motherboard
did looked around the DC,
found a couple of dozen of them run by.
We know who around US
government buildings.
I mean right now you can go on alibaba.com
buy one of those things for about a
thousand dollars in China.
They used to send spam two phones.
You get a software defined radio card,
you can download free software
and make your own right.
What started out as something that
was hard to do is now easy to do.
So those are my sort of six lessons that
are going to be true for everything and
none of that is new. But up to now it's
been basically a manageable problem.
But I think that's going to change.
And the reasons are automation,
autonomy and the physical agency,
computers that can do things.
So have you do computer security, you've
heard of the CIA triad, confidentiality,
integrity and availability.
Three basic properties.
We deal with insecurity by and large.
Most of what our issues are,
our confidentiality.
Someone stole and misused our data.
That's ecofacts.
That's office of personnel management.
That's Cambridge Analytica.
That's all the data thefts ever.
But when you get,
when you have computers that can affect
the world in a direct, physical manner,
integrity and availability
become much more serious
because the computers can do stuff.
There's real risk to life and property.
So yes,
I am concerned that someone hacks my
hospital and steals my private patient and
medical records, but I'm much more
concerned that they changed my blood type.
Yeah.
I don't want them to hack my car and use
the Bluetooth microphone to listen in
on conversations, but I really
don't want them to disable a breaks.
Those are data integrity and data
availability attacks respectively.
So suddenly the effects are much greater.
And this is cars, medical devices,
drones, any kind of weapon systems,
thermostats, a power plants, smart city,
anything.
Appliances.
Okay.
I blogged a couple of days ago about,
uh,
an attack where someone just theoretical,
if you can hack enough,
major appliances can turn power
on and off in synchronization and,
uh, affect the load on power plants
and potentially cause blackouts.
Now, very much a side effect. But once
I say that, you say, well yeah, Duh.
Of course you can do that.
Very different sort of attack,
right? There's a fundamental difference
between my spreadsheet crashes.
I may lose my data and my
implanted defibrillator
crashes and I lose my life and
it could be the same,
the same operating system,
the same vulnerability,
the same attack software because
of what the computer can do.
The effects are much difference,
so the same time we're getting
this increased functionality,
there's some long standing
security paradigms that are
failing and I give three.
The first one is patching and patching
is how we get security and it's now
having trouble actually of there's two
reasons why our phones and computers are
secure as they are.
The first is that there are security
engineers at apple and Microsoft at Google
that are designing it as secure as
they are in the first place and those
engineers can quickly write and push
down patches when vulnerabilities are
discovered. That's a pretty
good ecosystem. We do that well.
The problem is it doesn't work for low
cost embedded systems like dvrs and
routers.
These are designed and built
off shore by third parties,
by ad hoc teams that come together,
design them, and then split apart.
I mean there are people who can write
those patches when a vulnerability is
discovered. And even worse, a lot of
these devices have no way to patch them,
right? If your DVR is
vulnerable to the, uh, to the,
to the hack that, uh, allows
to be crucial with botnets,
the only way you can patch it is
to throw it away and buy a new one.
That's the mechanism we have no other
now actually throw it away and buy a new
one is a reasonable security measure.
We do get security.
The fact that the life cycle of,
of phones and computers is
about three to five years.
That's not true for consumer goods.
You're going to replace your DVR
every 10 years, your refrigerator,
every 25 years.
I bought a programmable thermostats
last year. I expect her a place.
It approximately never
think of it when,
think about it in terms of a
car or you buy a car today.
So let's say software is two years old,
you're going to drive it for 10 years,
sell it, someone else buys it,
drives her 10 years, they sell it,
someone else buys it, puts on a
boat, said to the South America,
whereas someone else in their buys it
drives or another 10 to 20 years and you
go home,
find a computer from 1976
try to boot it, try to run
it, try to make it secure.
We actually have no idea how to
secure 40 year old consumer software.
We have the faintest clue
and we need to figure it out.
So what does Christ will maintain?
A test bed of 200 chassies
per vulnerability testing
and for patch testing.
Is that the mechanism?
We're not going to be able to treat
these goods like we treat phones and
computers, you know, we
start forcing the computer,
the computer lifecycle onto
all these other things.
We are probably literally
gonna Cook the planet.
So we need some other
way and we don't have it.
Second thing that's failing as
authentication, right? It's,
we've always been only
okay at authentication,
but
authentication is going to change.
Right now,
fenestration tends to be me
authenticating to some object or service.
What we're going to see an explosion
in his thing to thing authentication.
We're objects into authenticate to
objects and it's going to be a lot of it.
Imagine a a driverless car or even some
kind of computer assisted driving car.
It want to authenticate to
thousands of other cars,
road signs,
emergency vehicles and and signals.
Lots of things.
And we don't know how to do that at scale,
but are you might have a hundred iot
objects in your orbit to authenticate to
each other. Let's 10,000
authentications, right? 1,000 objects,
a million authentications.
I mean,
right now this is tends to be our iot hub.
Do you have an Iot? Anything you
like to control it via your phone?
I'm not sure that scales to that many
things and while we can do things,
think that's an occasion.
It's very much a deliberate.
So right now when I get into my car,
this phone authenticates the
car automatically, right?
That works. Bluetooth works,
but it works because I was there to set
it up and I'll do that for 10 things for
20 things on not doing it for a thousand.
I'm not doing it for a million.
So we need some way to do this automatic
thing of the thing of authentication at
scale and we don't have it.
The third thing that's
failing is supply chain.
Supply chain security is
actually insurmountably hard now.
We've seen it.
You've seen the papers in the past year.
It's been one of two stories.
It's Kaspersky, right?
Should we trust a Russian
made antivirus program and uh,
who ae and ZTE should we trust
Chinese made phone equipment.
But that really is just
the tip of the iceberg.
There are other stories,
not just the U s turns out in 2014,
China banned Kaspersky. They
also ban SYMANTEC. By the way,
a 2017 I started from India.
Then if I'm 45 Chinese phone apps
that they say shouldn't be used, uh,
in 1997 and the people remember there a
worries in the u s about checkpoint and
Israeli made security product.
You know, should we trust it?
I also, I like a member, a 2008
program called Musha secrets,
which was an isis created encryption
program because of course you can't trust
western encryption programs but you know,
the country of origin of the product
is just the tip of the iceberg.
Where are the chips made?
Where is the software written?
Where is the device fab where
the programmers are far from.
I mean this iPhone probably has won a
couple of a hundred different passports
that are programming this thing.
It's not need in the U S and every
part of the chain is a vulnerability.
They are, they're a paper showing
how you can take a, you know,
a good chip design that the masks and
maliciously put in another layer and
calmed my security. The chip without the
designer's knowing it and it doesn't,
it doesn't show up in testing. There was
another paper about two years ago. Uh,
you can, uh, hack an iPhone through
a malicious replacement screen,
right? You have to trust
every piece of the system.
The distribution mechanisms.
We've,
we've seen backdoors in a
Cisco equipment. Uh, Mohammed,
the NSA intercepted, uh, the, uh,
Cisco routers being sent to
the Syrian telephone company.
That was one of the greatest
pictures from the stolen documents.
We've seen fake apps in
the Google play store.
We know that a Russia
attacked Ukraine through a,
a software update mechanism.
I think my favorite story is,
this is a hard one. In 2003,
there was actually a very clever,
very subtle backdoor that
almost made it into Linux.
We caught it and we kind
of just barely caught it.
We got very lucky there and,
and you look at the code,
it's, it really is hard. You have
to look for it to see the back door.
Now that could have easily gotten in.
We don't know what else has gotten in,
in watts
and solving this is hard.
No one wants a US only iPhone is probably
a impossible and beetle cost 10 x.
Now our industry is at
every level international.
It is deeply international
from the programmers to the, to the,
to the, the objects to the cloud,
the services. We will not be
able to solve the seasonally.
So,
and a lot of ways this is a perfect
storm and things are failing just as
everything is interconnected and will,
and I think we've been okay
with a unregulated tech
space because fundamentally
didn't matter.
And that's changing.
And I think this is primarily a
policy problem. And in my book,
I spend most of the time on policy
and I talk about a lot of different
policy levers we have to improve this.
Talking about standards,
regulations, liabilities, courts,
international treaties think it's
a very hard political battle.
And I don't think we're going to have
in the u s until a catastrophic event.
You know, I look more to Europe to
lead. I couldn't go through all of this,
but I want it to want to give sort
of two principles I want to pull out.
The first is that the fence must dominate.
I think we as a national policy need to
decide that defense wins that no longer
can we accept insecurity for offense
purposes that as these computers become
more critical,
defense is more important.
My gone are the days when you can
attack their stuff and defend our stuff.
Everyone uses the same stuff.
We all use TCP IP and Cisco Routers
and Microsoft Word and pdf files,
and it's just one world,
one network, one answer.
Either we secure our stuff,
thereby incidentally
securing the bad guy's stuff,
or we keep our stuff vulnerable
in order to attack the bad guys,
thereby incidentally rendering us
vulnerable and that's our choice
and it means it means a whole
bunch of things to disclose and fix
vulnerabilities to design for security,
not for surveillance,
encrypt as much as possible to
really separate security from spying,
make law enforcement smarter so they can
actually solve crimes even though their
security
and create better norms.
What other principle is that we
need to build for resilience?
When you start designing systems,
assuming they will fail and
how do we contain failures?
How do we avoid catastrophes?
How do we fail safe for fail secure?
Where can we remove
functionality or delete data?
How do we have systems monitor other
systems to try to provide, you know,
some level of redundancy.
And I think the missing piece here has
government that the market will not do
this on its own.
But I have a problem,
you know,
handing us to government because there
really isn't an existing regulatory
structure that could tackle this at a
systemic level grads because there's a
mismatch between the way government works
and the way tech works at government
operates in silos.
The FAA regulate aircraft,
the FDA regulates medical devices
or the FTC regulates consumer goods.
Someone else does those cars
and each agency will have its own
rules and on approach and own systems.
And that's not the internet or the
Internet is this freewheeling system of
integrated objects and and networks and
it grows horizontally and it kicks down
barriers and it makes people able
to do things never could do before.
And all of that rhetoric is true.
I mean,
right now this device logs
my health information,
communicates with my car,
monitors my energy use and
makes phone calls, right?
That's four different, probably
five different regulatory agencies.
And this is just getting started,
right?
We're not sure how to do this.
So in my book I talk about a
bunch of options and what I have,
and I think we're going to, we're
going to get eventually is a, a,
a new route and a new government agency
that will have some jurisdiction over
computers. Uh, this is a
hard sell to a, you know,
low government crowd.
But there is a lot of precedent for this.
In the last century,
pretty much all major technologies
led to the formation of new government
agencies. All right? Cars
did, planes did, radio did,
nuclear power did because government
needs to consolidate its expertise.
So, and that's what happens first.
And then there is need to regulate.
I don't think markets solved us,
Marcus or short term markets or profit
motivated markets don't take society into
account. Markets can't solve collection
at the collective action problems.
So of course there are lots
of problems with this, right?
Governments are terrible.
Being proactive,
a regulatory capture is,
are we is a real issue.
I think there are differences between
security and safety that matter here.
It's safety against things
like a hurricane and secure
it against an adaptive,
malicious, intelligent adversary are,
are sort of very different things.
And you know,
we live in a fast moving technological
environment and it's hard to see how
government can stay ahead of tech.
There's something that's changed in the
past couple of decades or tech moves
faster than policy.
The Devil's in the details and,
and I, I don't have them, but
yeah,
this is a conversation that we need to
have because I believe that governments
get involved regardless that the risks
are too great and the stakes are too
high, right? Or governments are
ready involved in physical systems.
They already regulate cars and
appliances and toys and power plants
and medical systems.
So they already have this ability and
need and desire to regulate those things
as computers. But how do we give
them the expertise to do it right?
Uh,
my guesses are the courts are going to
do some things relatively quickly because
cases will appear and that the
regulatory agencies will follow.
I think Congress comes last but don't
count them out and nothing motivates a,
a, a government. The US
government like fear.
Okay.
When you think back to the
terrorist attacks of September 11th,
we had a very small government
administration create a
massive bureaucracy kind
of out of thin air.
And that was all fear motivated.
And when something happens that will
be a push that something must be done.
And we are past the choice of government
involvement versus no government
involvement.
Our choice now is smart governor
involvement versus stupid government
involvement.
And the more we can talk about this now,
the more we could make sure it's smart.
Uh,
am I guess as any good regulation will,
uh,
send private industry that I think the
reason we have such bad security is not
technological,
it's more economic.
There's lots of good tech and you know,
while some of these problems are hard,
they're like send a man to the moon hard.
They're not Fastenal.
I travel hard.
Yeah.
And once the incentives
are in place in this story,
we'll figure out how to do it right.
I mean a good example,
it might be credit cards.
In the early days of credit cards,
we were all liable for a for fraud and
losses that change in 1978 the fair
credit reporting act,
that's what a mandated the maximum
liability for credit card fraud for the
consumer is $50 and he
understood what that means.
That means I could take my card
flinging in the middle of this room,
give you all lessons on forging my
signature and my maximum liability is $50
right?
It might be worth it for the fun,
but what that meant, right? That change
that even if the consumer is at fault,
the credit card company is liable.
That led to all sorts of security measures
that led to online verification of
uh,
of credit and card validity that led to
anti forgery measures like the holograms
and the micro printing blood to mailing
the card and the activation information
separately and requiring you to
call from a known phone number.
And actually most importantly,
that enabled the backend expert
systems that troll the, uh,
credit, the transaction database,
looking unfortunately spending patterns,
none of that would've happened if the
consumers reliable because the consumers
had no ability to implement any of that.
You want the entity that can fix the
problem to be responsible for the problem.
That is just smart policy.
So I see a lot of innovation that's not
happening because the incentives are
mismatched. So I think Europe
is moving in this direction,
right?
The EU is right now the regulatory
superpower on the planet and they are not
afraid to use their power. We've seen
that in the Gdpr in the privacy space.
I think they're going to turn
to security next. I mean,
they're already working on what
responsible disclosure means. Uh,
there's that you have to
see on manufactured goods.
Does that label called CE?
That's an EU label basically means uh,
meets all applicable standards.
They're working on standards for
cybersecurity and you know, useful.
See them get incorporated
trade agreements into Gat.
And there's an interesting,
a rising tide effect.
It's not necessarily obvious the the car
you buy a United States is not the car
you buy in Mexico.
Right?
Environmental laws are different and
the cars are tuned to the different laws
but not true in the computer space.
The uh,
the Facebook you get is pretty
much the same everywhere.
And if you can imagine there's
some security regulation on a toy,
the manufacturer meets it.
They're not going to have a
separate build for United States.
They're going to sell it
everywhere cause it's easier
that, and they'll, there'll
be times when that's not true.
I think Facebook would like to be able
to differentiate between someone who is
subject to the Gdpr is somebody who's
not cause there's more revenue to be
gained through them, the greater
surveillance. But when you get to things,
I think it's more likely that it will
be a rising tide and we all benefit.
United States are look to the states more
specifically New York, Massachusetts,
California, which are more
aggressive, uh, in this space.
But I think this is coming
and
I want to close with a,
I guess a call.
What we need to do is to
get involved in policy.
Technologists need to get in
policy to get involved in policy.
As Internet security becomes everything.
Security,
Internet security technology becomes more
important to overall security policy.
And all of the security policy
debates will have strong technological
components.
We will never get the policy right if
the policy makers get the tech wrong,
right? It will all look like the Facebook
hearings, which were embarrassing.
And you see it even in some of you
see it in the going dark debate.
You see it in the equities debate,
you see it and voting machine debates in
driverless car security debates that we
need technologists in the room
during policy discussions, right?
We have to fix this.
We need technologists on congressional
staffs at Ngos doing investigative
journalism in the government
agencies in the White House,
right?
We need to make this happen.
And right now you just
don't have that ecosystem.
So you think about a public interest law
1970s there was no such thing as public
interest law.
They would actually wasn't.
It was created primarily by the
Ford Foundation. Oddly enough,
that funded law clinics,
funded internships in different NGOs and
now you want to make partner at a major
law firm. You are expected
to do public interest work
today at Harvard,
Harvard Law School,
20% of the graduating class doesn't
go into corporations or law firms.
They go into public interest law and the
university has soul searching seminars
because that percentage is so low.
Percentage of computer science
graduates is probably zero. Right?
We need to fix that. And that's
more than just, you know,
every Google or needs to do an internship
because there aren't spaces for those
people.
So we got to fix the supply,
got to fix the demand and the
ecosystem to link the two.
And this is of course
the bigger than security.
I think pretty much all the major
societal problems of this century have a
strong tech component or climate change,
future of work,
farm policy.
And we need to be in the room
or bad policy happens to us.
So that's my talk.
There's of course a lot more in the book
that I didn't say and I'm happy to take
questions.
[inaudible] alright.
Do you imagine that some
of the sociopolitical,
uh, things that we're seeing crop
up fit within this framework? Uh,
or do you think that that
might be an entirely separate,
that needs an entirely
separate set of solutions?
I think it's related.
I mean there's problems,
I'm talking about a
pretty purely technical,
the problem is of a internet as proper
as a propaganda vehicle are I think much
more systemic and societal.
Uh,
I do blame surveillance capitalism
for, for a bunch of it, right?
The business model that a prioritizes
engagement rather than quality has learned
that if you're pissed off,
you stay on Facebook more so.
So I think there are, are,
are pieces that fit in. So
some related, some different,
I mean, you shouldn't be talking a lot
about policy that the United States,
it's to some extent the EU can do.
But I wonder what do you think
will happen as policy everywhere?
We policies local, the rns global.
Right? How's that going to play out?
So I think that never goes away. And
some that's going to be the rising tide.
I talked about that especially
with, you know, less about privacy.
But when you get to safety,
I think it's more likely that we benefit
from a European regulation that ensures
that,
you know,
the smart vacuum cleaner you bought
can't be taken over by somebody and then
like attack you and trip you.
Right.
Well W W we likely the benefit
of that more than, look,
you can't have a microphone
on the thing. Okay. Uh,
we have to assume that there will be
malicious things in whatever system we
have.
And so if we have a US only regulation,
it'll clean up a lot of the problem
because Walmart and we'll be able to sell
the bad stuff. But you can still buy it
and mail order from alibaba.com right?
So there will be some stuff in
the network that is malicious,
much lower percentage is your problem.
We're still going to
have to deal with that.
And I don't think it ever goes away
because we're not going to have a world
government though will be a jurisdiction
or they will be homebrew stuff that
doesn't meet whatever regs we have that.
But that will always happen.
You talk about the need for intelligent
technologists to get involved with main
policy, but there are only so many
hours in a day and we'd probably,
most of us would be taking a huge pay
cut to go work in government and under
expertise there. So what, how
can we fix the incentives there?
So some of it is desire.
I mean,
I know ACLU attorneys that are making a
third of what they would make at a big
law firm and they get more resumes
than they have positions, right?
So it works in law.
The desire to actually make the world
better turns out to be a prime motivator.
So I think once we have the ecosystem,
we will get the supply.
I think that enough of us will say,
you know, we've had great careers.
We're going to take a break or are we
going to do something before we go work at
a startup or a big company or maybe
that mean there will be a use for
sabbaticals like you see in law firms
or you know your bits of pro bono work,
you know like a 20% project.
So I mean, yes you will.
People will be making less money.
I don't think that is going
to harm the system or you can,
we just need to get the system working.
The most jarring thing I saw you write
as a Googler was a date day is a toxic
assets.
Uh, what, what can I know a lot of.
So
the promise of big data has been save
it all figured out what to do with it
later and that's been driven by the
marginal cost of saving it has dropped to
zero is basically cheaper now to save
it all and to figure out what to save.
This storage is free processing is free,
transport is free.
But it turns out that data is a toxic
asset that for most companies having it is
enormous liability because
someone's going to hack it.
So it's going to get stolen,
you're going to lose it.
And I think we need to start talking
about data not as this sort of magic
goodness,
but it no decays and value the end that
there are dangers and storing it or the
the best way to secure your data is to
delete it and you're going to delete it
if you don't know if you
know you don't need it.
I swear I've seen lots of studies on data,
on and shopping preferences and it
turns out some pieces of data are very
valuable in a lot of it
just isn't very valuable.
So is it worth the extra quarter percent
of accuracy to have this day that is
potentially dangerous and we'll get you
find or embarrassed and you'll take a
stock,
takes a hit if it gets stolen.
So I think we need to make more of those
decisions that the data is radioactive.
It's toxic, right? We keep it
if we need to, but if we don't,
we get rid of it and we figure how
to get rid of it safely and securely.
Hey, I mean take, oh, I don't know ways,
right ways is a surveillance based system.
Very personal data,
but probably only valuable if for
like 10 minutes or at least you know,
can can be sampled in lots of ways.
I can treat that data
understanding it's a toxic asset,
get my value at much less
risk to my organization.
And that's what I mean by that.
It's interesting that there are
ways to anonymize stuff. Uh,
but there seems to be
no demand and no supply.
He said there are marginally more
expensive to do federated machine learning
than do everything in the center.
But companies don't care.
And consumers a decidedly.
Yeah,
consumers, consumers
don't care. That's why,
I mean you need these decisions made not
by consumers, but by citizens. Right?
Consumers don't care,
right?
Consumers are buying the big Mac at 10%
off because you was truly don't care.
The point of purchase, nobody
cares. At the point of reflection,
people care a lot.
And that's,
you don't want the market doing this.
You want us as our best selves doing this.
So and about an entity,
it is harder than you think.
You most of our ways of Anna
and anonymizing data fails.
It is a very hard problem. We
don't, the anonymity research is,
is,
is really,
I mean the breaking any research is very
good these days and outstripping the
anonymity research.
Go to the next,
one of the things that I'm thinking about
is a lot of times when you see like a
big vulnerability, so say there's a
big operating system vulnerability,
it's actually a genuine mistake of
it's not that someone, you know,
put it in there on purpose,
it's they missed something.
So how does regulation solve that problem
of surely you could have some great
regulation in place that something
supposed to be done a certain way, but oh,
the implementation was slightly offer,
slightly broken. How do you fix that?
You know,
genuine mistake.
Even if they were trying to do what the
regulations specified as this would be a
secure system.
So you'd be surprised.
But a financial motive [inaudible]
money motivates companies.
If companies will be fine, a lot of
money, if their employees make a mistake,
they figured out a way to their
employees to make fewer mistakes.
But doesn't that only take effect after
the mistake has already been, you know,
like the evil has already been,
but there's a deterrence
effect. Okay. And so, so yes,
I mean like arresting someone for
murder only takes effect after he's done
murder.
But the goal is that the threat of being
arrested for murder will keep you from
hurting someone tomorrow. And so, so
we, we want this deterrence effect, uh,
how to produce software mistakes.
We actually know a lot of techniques that
pretty much all software manufacturers
and never do because it would
be slightly more expensive.
But if it's a lot more expensive not to
do them, it's suddenly the math changes.
And I need the math to change.
I need security to be cheaper
than insecurity right now.
The market rewards,
let's just take the chance,
right? You know, let's hope for
the best. Okay. And then it,
no industry, I say this already,
remind me. Yes, no, no. Okay.
No industry in the past a hundred and
something years has improved security and
safety without being forced to
cars,
planes, pharmaceuticals, medical devices,
food production,
restaurants, consumer goods,
workplace.
Most recently financial products,
the market rewards, doing a
bad job, hoping for the best.
And I think it's too risky
to allow that anymore.
Uh,
so you mentioned that you were embarrassed
by the Zuckerberg hearings and I was
embarrassed by the questions at the
Zuckerberg decides to be fair look,
congressmen embarrassment. So I,
yeah, so I, I so I assumed correctly,
I assume were embarrassed
by the senator's. Yes, yes.
Whereas I have the opposite problem. I
was embarrassed by it. Zuckerberg, what,
what I give me fair. There's a
lot of embarrassment to go around,
but we can both be writers. Stan. Yeah.
But I, I have a serious point here though,
is that, uh, while the
senators don't know about tech,
I think the tech doesn't
know about law ethics,
political science philosophy.
Like,
do you think mark Zuckerberg can even
teach an introductory college course on
free speech? Like has even read like
what anyone has ever said about it.
So like shouldn't we all be learning
about the world around this? This
has to go in both directions. Yes.
Right.
I want techies and politicians.
I won policy people in tech companies.
So yes, I think we need both.
We need both sides talking
to each other. Right. And so,
so I agree with you 100% good.
Okay.
Alright.
So right now I teach Internet security
at the Harvard Kennedy School at a public
policy institution. So I'm trying to go,
you know, push people in that direction.
At the same time,
there are people at Harvard computer
science department trying to teach policy
issues to go the other direction.
I think you probably know a lot of stuff.
I know,
but I'm not in charge.
You mentioned like sort
of shock events, uh, as,
as things that drive government policy.
And I thought the example of nine 11 was
like instructive maybe in a way you did
or did not intend in that
like the government response
to nine 11 was to launch
two illegal wars and create a
surveillance state that violates our civil
liberties on a date. So I did
intend, not sure. That's a good,
like I guess I'm curious how you,
terrible life.
So how do you see the reaction to the
reaction to the mounting threats in
technology as being different?
What's going to prevent the same
sort of thing from absolutely
nothing. Okay. And then that's the,
and that's my fear that
something bad will happen.
Congress will say something must be done.
This is something,
therefore we must do it.
All right.
So my goal of having this conversation
now before this happens is that we will,
as a community figure out what should
be done when we have the luxury of time
and insights and patients.
And because I agree with you
that there is a disaster,
we will get a disaster as a
response and it will be just as bad.
So let's get ahead of it this
time. Let's do better. How do you,
uh,
envision preventing everything
a degenerating to the
lowest common denominator?
Like you said,
client side,
you can't really restrict people
from doing what they want. You know,
even if we say,
okay,
any company that wants to make money in
the u s has to follow these provisions,
I'm just going to encrypt my data
and send it to Ali Baba Plate.
It's a third of the price of Google
translate. But they all my data,
like how do we prevent this?
Is there anything we can do?
You know, some of it in the answer's
gonna be no psalm. It's gonna be yes.
So if you think about uh,
other consumer goods,
we do make it hard for
consumers to modify something.
It's actually hard to modify your car
to violate emissions control, right?
You can do it, but it's hard. And
then we try to have spot checks.
You can imagine some sort of regime,
you can imagine some system that tries
to maintain security anyway cause it will
be up and just a minority doing that.
I think once we start
hitting the problem for real,
we'll come up with tech solutions and
ways the system to self to watch itself,
other systems to watch each other.
What can we do this noninvasively?
I think we have to figure it out. All
right. So I don't have the answers here,
but I mean these are
certainly the problems.
I,
uh,
I really liked your phrasing
of the problem of we need
to give up on offense so
we can go all in on defense. And, um, I,
I think it's pretty clear to me where a
lot of the offensive focuses in terms of
law enforcement, but I think one
thing that sort of remains, uh,
mostly an unknown is on the military
side and how there is a ton of investment
in military oftens of stuff.
We kind of know, you know,
a little bit more maybe about
like what Russia and China are,
are using offensively against us.
We're not seeing the good stuff yet.
I hope not anyway. Right. Yeah.
Uh, but, but do we, do we have a
sense of, of what the military did,
the u s military,
let's say,
would be giving up to give up
this, this offensive, uh, idea.
And,
and uh,
I don't know how willing they would be
to go with that direction. They wouldn't
be willing,
but it's not their job to be willing.
I mean it's why you don't want the NSA
in charge of your privacy policy because
it's not their job. You know, we
need people above the military,
the NSA to make these trade offs because
they are security versus security trade
offs.
Right.
Is the security we get from being able
to spy out and hack the bad guys greater
or less than the security we get from
the bad guys being unable to spy on and
hack us. I that's great. It's so,
I mean it's security versus surveillance
was the wrong way to describe it as
security versus security.
So someone above this, the,
the military needs to decide that it
can't be the military because the military
is not in charge of overall policy.
They don't charge of the military part.
And what we know about the
capabilities is very little.
I mean we get some shadows of it here
or there and it seems to be, you know,
we, you know, on the one hand cruder
than we were then we'd like it to be.
On the other hand, you know, stuxnet
was pretty impressive. You know,
in general the stuff you see
as sort of the minimum tech,
it has to be to succeed. Right?
This sort of this myth of this,
these, uh, you know,
super powerful cyber attacks
that basically, you know,
one I owed them more than just
barely necessary to succeed.
You know,
you don't need to do more if he could
take out the DNC with a pretty sloppy
phishing campaign. And why, I mean,
why bother using your good stuff?
So a lot we just don't know
at risk of revisiting an earlier question.
Um,
I was interested in
what you thought about,
so like one of the things that's often
you'll see cynical in the finance
industry is that they think that people
in finance can out maneuver all the
people who are regulating them in
part because of the lesser paid.
So I was wondering if you could revisit
that cause I think La has maybe the
exception because it's a little bit more
directly related to human rights and
things like that that,
yeah, I don't know. I mean, certainly,
uh, I worry about regulatory capture,
uh, regulations being evaded. I think
the, all of those are real risks. I mean,
this is not a great answer. I have,
it's just the best one I have.
Yeah.
Cause I don't see any way
to put a backstop against,
so this massive corporate power
other than government power.
Now in a sense out of Keto one,
either power,
but tech naturally concentrates power
at least as it's configured today.
So that's my missing piece.
I think you're right that that is a
serious problem in worry and something we
just have to deal with. Okay.
Policies iterative as techies.
It's hard to,
to accept that we like to get the answer
right and then implemented where's
policy gets the answer. Like slightly
relaxed wrong every few months.
Hm.
But that's, you know, that's
the way it works. I mean,
the real question is can we do this
at tech speed? And that it really is,
I think it's an open question
so that I'm going to end.
Thank you all. Thanks for
filling the room. Thanks.
[inaudible].